foreign
[Music]
for leaving a family gathering because
my family made me sit at the kid table
for context I haven't seen my full
family together in quite some time so
they set up a get-together at a park
today the family gathering includes me
my brother my sister her husband and
their two kids my dad my stepmom and her
kids Aunt Uncle my two cousins Grandma
and Grandpa and he's a 22 year old male
I get there with not the Grandpa's not
22 year old male but but the person
running this is I get there with some
picnic items I brought a quiche and the
cups
and I see a few members setting up I say
hi and help set up the tables and set
the food out one problem I'm running
into was already with the Mi things it's
like way too much information just get
get right to the point I don't need to
know what you all had for your picnic
what does that have to do with anything
anyway so I sit next to my dad and I get
a weird look from my aunt as she says to
me this is the adults table to which I
reply I'm an adult she says that the
first and second Generations are
considered adults
on the third and fourth generation
should sit at the kids table I tell her
that I can drink that I drove here and
that I pay rent and have a job so how am
I still considered a child she says that
until I have kids of my own I'll have to
sit at the Kids Table according to my
author eight children ages 6 to 22 and
eight adults ages 25 to 75. so I should
just sit at the Kids Table uh and then
he proceeds to storm out and he takes
his quiche with him and he leaves and he
wants to know if he's the
uh yes you are I knew it I'm surrounded
by myself number one because you brought
a quiche okay you're going to a picnic
what kind of man
brings a quiche to a picnic in the first
place I don't even know if I'm
pronouncing that correctly
uh you bring chips you bring beer okay
or something along those lines
and also your child is ridiculous for
storming out
proving by your behavior ironically that
you are worthy of the children's table
at Best in fact your you should be a
step dad this should be like a third
table just for you because uh because my
kids are at the at the kids table and
they wouldn't and I would not allow them
to act like this and besides here's the
thing you need to understand as a man
and your aunt who brought this up I
think is correct you aren't going to be
fully accepted as a grown man until you
get married and have kids
that's that's just the way it is I'm not
saying it should be that way
well I mean I am saying it should be
that way but that's not the main point
that that is how people see it
and uh so if you want to graduate to the
to the adult table then you have to have
kids of your own you know you use
basically look look at this way this way
you supply your own replacement for the
Kids Table once you have your own kid
they sit there you get to graduate to
the adult team
[Music]
all right um am I the uncle for
assigning my family homework and not
visiting until it's done I recently quit
my PhD program to get a job because I
realized Academia was not what I wanted
and I was better off just using my
masters to get a job everyone I know
from school or has experience with grad
school agreed I'm doing the right thing
because I've only done one year of PhD
classes so it's a good time to quit I've
had to tell people uh that this and that
and so and so forth my family were not
understanding none of them have ever
been to grad school but they believe
that I was very far along and quitting
at the last minute I've told them one
year of classes is nothing but they
don't realize how hard the exam and
dissertation are okay where does the
homework come in I figured if they
wouldn't listen to me they might listen
to someone else I found an article by
college professor that describes what
it's like to get a PhD in my field I
told them I would not visit until they
read the article and wrote a few
paragraphs summarizing the article and
discussing why someone may choose not to
get a PhD it's not meant to be a long
and difficult project I just want them
to understand my point of view my
boyfriend and my siblings did their
essays and apologized what and my
boyfriend went above and beyond by
including other sources besides the
article so I hit I think her boyfriend
is the guy that brought the quiche to
the picnic so this is all all is this is
all the same universe where this is
happening my parents still haven't done
their essays and haven't apologized and
still complain that I'm throwing away
all the work I did okay
um you're the you're the actual you're
like double triple A whole material here
you're just an first you
enrolled in a PhD program for no reason
at all and then you quit you you're the
one who didn't do your homework maybe
you should have read that article before
you signed up for the PHD program
and sunk all this money into it for a
year
um here's the thing about PHD programs
like master's degree degrees also in
like 98 of cases are giant scams and
that's where you find this uh this weird
kind of like disconnect because you
think of people that have all these
letters next to their names it's a sign
of intelligence no oftentimes it's a
sign of stupidity that you were too dumb
to realize what a waste of time this was
and uh you did it anyway so
here's a-hole for that reason
and then you try to give a homework
assignment to your family members and
your boyfriend is also an a-hole for
actually completing the assignment
and so are your siblings I can't I have
five siblings
if I were to tell them here's the
assignment and I need you all write me a
3s three paragraph essay an apology they
would laugh at my face
so
everyone in your family including you
they're all a-holes except for your
parents they're the only ones who come
out looking okay here except that they
raised you
which makes them a holes too so this is
just an a-hole Bonanza
[Music]
another one says my husband and I have
been married for six years still don't
have kids we want them but still not
happening friends and family are causing
us constant stress about having a baby
soon but it's obviously something we
can't control so what I did was come up
with an idea to have an empty jar and
call it the pregnancy jar I carry it
with me in my bag whenever I'm with my
friends and family and every time
somebody asks about when my husband and
I are going to have a baby I pull my jar
out and ask them to put a dollar in
there for asking
then they pull out a dollar and they put
it inside they actually do it it
actually worked because most of them
stopped asking after about four months
last week we had dinner at my parents
house my brother came back from his
business trip that lasted a month and
while we were eating he asked when me
and my husband were gonna have a kid
with my jar in my hand asked them to
drop a dollar for the question he asked
I could tell he felt embarrassed but he
immediately reached out of his pocket
pulled out his wallet and put it taller
in the jar made my way back to my seat
and sat down and resumed eating like
nothing happened this is
and everybody in the comments and I
scroll down everybody in the comments
has somehow declared that this woman is
NTA right not the somehow
and that is exactly why you don't turn
to Reddit for moral Enlightenment that's
why you have to turn to me because yes
you are the a-hole every single one so
far everyone involved is Diego if you're
actually cooperating with this and
encouraging this Behavior someone puts a
jar in front of me and says this is my
pregnancy jar I put a dollar in it what
no get away from me for me freak people
ask that question
because they're taking an interest in
you
and they want to know about your life we
all have certain questions that are
asked of us all the time by everybody
and that we're annoyed about
but that's the price of living in a
human society even if it's a little bit
weird it's still people taking an
interest in you and so that is your
responsibility to just deal with it and
make it less awkward not more and that's
the other problem is that okay somebody
asks a question to you
and it's a little bit awkward you don't
want to answer it
well the objective now should be to
neutralize the awkwardness and move on
from it as quickly as possible you've
brought everyone else into this
awkwardness I can only imagine sitting
there at this dinner table as a guest
and watching this whole exchange taking
place
how do you move on from that and have a
regular conversation
saw your Ollie holes
[Music]